voici le nouveau passeport avec un
nouveau design sur la page couverture à
l'intérieur une foule de caractéristique
de sécurité comme par exemple les
informations personnelles du détenteur
seront en polycarbonate comme sur les
dollars ou les permis de conduire ces
renseignements ne seront plus aussi
imprimés mais plutôt gravées pour rendre
leur contrefaçon plus difficile
sur la photo du détenteur un kiné-gramme
ou une modification microscopique de
l'image sera également ajouté là on
passe vraiment dans une secure une très
bonne sécurité donc je pense qu'on a
fait on fait un bon vraiment très
important en termes de difficulté de de
falsifier de créer des faux passeports
avec avec toutes ces techniques qu'on
rajoute pour le gouvernement il s'agit
d'un nouveau document fiable et sûr il y
a beaucoup de nouveaux caractéristiques
qui renforcent la sécurité à de notre
passeport qui est un des plus fiable
document de voyage dans le monde je
crois que les Canadiens peuvent être
vraiment fiers un nouveau passeport donc
et aussi une nouvelle façon de le
renouveler à compter de l'automne
prochain il sera en effet possible de
faire une nouvelle demande par le biais
d'une application en ligne ce qui
soulève quelques questions de sécurité
la demande ne se passe pas cela passe
par là du côté
internet qu'on peut faire des demandes
puis là c'est sûr que l'on tombe au
niveau des risques informatiques ça peut
être une chose positive du moment qu'on
fait bien attention à quels sont les
données qui sont demandées à une
personne le nouveau passeport serait
disponible au cours des prochains mois
le temps que les anciens documents
soient écoulés entre temps et bien
l'actuel passeport demeure valide en
tout temps ici Jacques Bissonnière
Radio-Canada Montréal